I like the idea of somebody who's like a
washed up celebrity and they're on the
list and they're like show The List come
on
Vanessa
or Carlton from The Fresh Prince
show the list show the list
[Music]
the U.S Virgin Islands Islands have not
have sex yet has subpoenaed Elon Musk
requesting documents from the
billionaire for the government's lawsuit
alleging JP Morgan Chase benefited
financially from Jeffrey Epstein's sex
trafficking operation I've read that
headline like seven thousand times I
don't know what the [__] it means so
they're going after the big boys off but
what does that mean what does that have
to do with what does Elon have to do
with JP Morgan Chase and [__] Epstein
so apparently it's it's as simple as
he's not in trouble in any way why does
it sound like he's in trouble well he's
at the principal's office the petition
to served the subpoena does not
implicate musk in any wrongdoing and
merely indicates that he was a high net
worth individual whom Epstein may have
introduced to JP Morgan so he was like
there so they wanted subpoena subpoena
him to bring him in and basically yeah
ask questions again like what was
Epstein light that's a long shot that
sounds like a super long shot they just
want to get Elon to speak on whether the
connection was beneficial for JP Morgan
right because why does it sound like
elon's in trouble he's not in trouble it
sounds like it but no they're just he's
a witness they want they want potential
information so they're just asking him
to come and give his opinions on Epstein
and JPMorgan Chase yeah oh because he
was a high Person of Interest that like
was like met with them right at some
point because it sounds like it's I
thought like [__] Elon was gonna go
to jail or some [__] it sounds like by
putting it out publicly it pressures
into want to go in right ah interesting
yeah the government contacted Mr musk's
Council via email to ask if he would be
authorized to accept service on Mr must
be half in this matter but did not
receive a response confirming or deny
his authority the subpoenas requesting
all Communications between musk and JP
Morgan regarding Epstein or any role the
disgraced financier played in the Tesla
CEO's financial management what a pain
in the ass if Epstein was also just
involved with Tesla's like financial
management and stuff like that during
that time then another thing to bring
him in question what does subpoena even
mean you're forced to come like that's
government court order you ever been
subpoenaed you've been served you ever
served somebody else
when they're like you know pretending to
play some other role like a UPS driver
or something like that you're like Mr
Quan uh yeah you've been served does it
really work like that in real life I
don't know it's only in the movies it's
kind of cool yeah I do know that you
have to you can't do it yourself right
you can't subpoena the person that
you're trying yeah oh yeah go ahead and
say it subpoena
right yeah you know where
that's all right
because oh because then it yeah there's
some uh you have to have like a middle
person oh yeah or something like a
notary kind of thing yeah right one of
my friends had his buddy do it yeah you
could have a person or a professional
service you can have a police officer do
it too right right I got randomly I got
served a few weeks ago uh or not a
subpoena I got yeah I got served not
subpoena uh someone sued me yeah I had
my first lawsuit for for the towing cool
not like I was in college you're winning
everything why what was the what on what
grounds
um we impounded somebody's car they
parked somewhere they weren't supposed
to they got towed and then they sued us
they sued the property manager they sued
the property the owner Property Owners
they're going for blood this is the size
of that person's dick right now whoa
that's that's pretty good size so small
you know when you're like super mad and
it's like like irrational and you're
like I want to sue everybody yeah that's
pretty gangster what's their cause yeah
um just to make you jump through hoops
on right uh yeah was it it would be rich
like that illegal illegal well I think
what he was hoping for is that we would
settle
um you're like oh we don't want to go
through this like because like we don't
want any blemishes though we have a
clean company so we don't want to
blemish if you sue if you get soda you
lose it's on your record right you know
we don't we don't want but you wouldn't
lose something this simple no we went
for we would even use our lawyers I just
straight up did it myself
you win everything
yours is fight shorts and [__] okay yeah
yeah you're good bro I just finished
digging a tree
this lawsuit's been sponsored by Barbara
Brigade JK news
I just wanted for the record
so to to paint more contacts to this in
2022 the U.S Virgin Islands filed a
lawsuit against JPMorgan Chase alleging
the Wall Street giant benefited
financially from Epstein's sex
trafficking operation and failed in its
duty to report suspicious Financial
activity called over more than a decade
JP Morgan clearly knew it was not
complying with federal regulations in
regard to Epstein related accounts as
evidenced by its two little too late
efforts after Epstein was arrested on
federal sex trafficking charges and
shortly after his death
so
the accounts that he maintained at JP
Morgan right now they're alleging that
they were like all principal business
accounts for human trafficking so is it
always like that when when somebody
invests in your company right and you
didn't know that the money was
ill-gotten gains that always falls on
you no matter what I mean this is saying
that JP Morgan clearly knew it was not
complying with federal regulations in
regard to epstein-related accounts
because the same thing's happening right
now with that Jolo guy and Leonardo
Dicaprio and all those movies that were
funded
it's the same thing this really fine
this rich financier guy was financing on
these films using like bad money that
was like gotten through some kind of
political like Strife so now they're
going back and they're going to all the
things that he paid for and they're like
did you know did you know did you know
and if anybody says they didn't know
they have to really prove they didn't
whoa that's kind of hard it's super hard
what if like the name of the accounts
was like for sex trafficking or not for
a sex trafficking
like that's how you organized it and
then JB was like hey oh dude I don't
even know what you're talking about sex
trap what is that really is sex
trafficking a tax deductible
who knows who knows what kinds of things
their lawyers are telling them to say
you know like if they did know there's
probably a million ways to get out of it
probably honestly at that level yeah if
they if they already knew they already
had the game plan way ahead of time
yeah it's JP Morgan they're pretty big
they could they could kill you if you
want yeah I mean this says that JP
Morgan Chase CEO Jamie Diamond is scary
dude his name is Jamie Diamond oh my God
what dude who is he is the guy who made
girls gone wild
what's up I'm Jamie diamonds
he's scheduled to be deposed at the end
of this month what is that you give me
these [__] words
so they bring him into the room for a
deposition where they Grill them
basically and get a deposition what's
the deposition it's a fancy meeting
isn't it so like when you go to the the
bank and you make a deposit
so what's your story how what do you fit
into this and then the guy writes it all
down and then when they take it to court
they go he said earlier that he didn't
know
my cousin Vinnie terms yeah
yeah
fits that description official like
statement or story exactly yeah yeah
yeah yeah and uh the Virgin Islands also
subpoenaed Google co-founder Larry Page
but was facing difficulty serving him as
well a court filing an earlier amazing
Google's other co-founder Sergey Brin as
well as Hyatt Hotels chair Thomas
pritzker real estate Tycoon and U.S news
world report owner Mort Zuckerman it's
not Hilton and entertainment executive
Michael Ovis were issued subpoena so it
looks like a lot of like high-profile
major like you know mobiles are getting
subpoenaed for this Epstein JP Morgan
the whole thing those are always crazy
because then that means like like for
your deposition your first one has to be
on point because that's the one they're
going to go back to and go hey it
doesn't match when you first told us a
to B to C and if they're doing all of
them like all the subpoenas everybody
got to meet up that night and go what
are we [__] saying bro
[__] happy that we're moving forward
on this Epstein [__] though the what
that there's progress on this whole
Epstein thing except for how the freak
he died yeah I mean that's the thing
that they're hiding and stuff but like
it just shows
how much of a bigger like play or bigger
picture it is I forgot which podcast I
was listening to
but they're talking about how like the
night that he died
um so you know how like the cameras are
off and then the security guy like fell
asleep yeah and then also it was
um that night when it happened the every
like I guess uh unit or block of a jail
they have its own like security to go in
that one was locked so it was locked so
no one could get inside but somehow all
the cells in that were open so all cell
mates are walking around and then
um and then after Epstein kills himself
that guy's cellmate is immediately
transferred to another jail so it was
like super high level yeah orchestration
that's not suspicious yeah like like how
the [__] is the CIA yeah the one day
this guy you can't get into the bigger
jail but all the cell doors opened that
night and the cameras off and the guy
that guy that is his cellmate is in
another
facility now it's like what the f I
can't believe you think Epstein killed
himself dude that's [__] cool I
thought yeah I can't believe you think
that I might change my mind okay but you
got to prove something to me
that's [__] crazy it is insane man
but yeah again like the like the list
you know that whole thing where the
everyone's like chooseless but it's like
you can't because you got to go down
that list and prove if you can even talk
about the names right Chris Tucker yeah
because each one of those people can sue
you even Chris even Chris my gosh
I think it's much a famous like a female
artist really Beyonce is it Beyonce on
that list well Blue Ivy I was actually
on the islands oh wow Northwest was yeah
yeah no but I think I think what Epstein
was doing was like he's a socialite so
he'd get really famous people that like
people want to hang out with and hang
around and then use those people as
pawns to like Leverage probably higher
profile people with like really I
thought you're gonna say it's like just
a chicken's like hey what island is this
oh no it's chill Island we're just gonna
chill back hey what are these children
doing here gotcha mother ever [__]
Jamie Diamond I like the idea of
somebody who's like a washed up
celebrity and they're on the list and
they're like show The List come on
Fred baby
baby come on man or Carlton from The
Fresh Prince Alfonso Roberto dude show
the list show the list
foreign
[Music]